normally i start one of my videos with a
funny intro but since it's the holidays
and i literally just ate 20 for our
roches as a meal we're gonna take it
easy and have a cozy wheel of time
fireside chat we'll be going over stuff
like how pat and fein got the dagger
naive's resurrection and what's next for
maureen and rand and don't worry for
those worried about book spoilers i'll
save those till the very end and will
warn you beforehand the final episode
titled the eye of the world is the
location that i sedai sorceress moraine
de madrid believes the dark one was in
prison several thousand years ago but
she calls this into question when
ishamail appears he is not the dark one
as the show might have you believe
rather one of the forsaken a group of
legendary channelers who serve the
shadow but i'm getting a bit ahead of
myself we have to go back 3000 years to
the end of the age of legends also known
as the second age this was a time before
the dark one corrupted the male half of
the one power making it impossible for
men to channel without being driven to
madness the one power is a form of magic
in the wheel of time and it is split
into both a male and female part we get
to meet the man who is able to cage the
dark one loose there an event which also
resulted in the male half of the one
power being corrupted this is why there
are no male channelers in the third age
we also see how 3 000 years ago things
were much more technologically advanced
something that was stifled with the dark
one's advances rand is coming hot off
the heels of learning he is the dragon
reborn a channeler of immense power that
will either save or destroy humanity so
moraine brings him to the eye of the
world in the hopes he will be able to
cage the dark one yet again they must
travel through the blight corrupted land
that emanates from the dark one's prison
its rapid growth suggests the dark one's
powers are growing with it we see the
blight has completely overtaken the city
of malkier who lan moraine's water was
in line to be king of speaking of him
there is a love affair between him and
naive however it'll likely be a
forbidden one since she says a wisdom
never weds her wisdom never wet in a
dream a shamael tells ran that he
doesn't stand a chance against the dark
one the last reborn came with 99
companions all of them stronger than
moraine what chance does he have but
moraine has a secret weapon a san graal
this object was created from the one
power itself when a thousand male
channelers put the entirety of their
strength into it when you channel with
it it increases your power a
hundred-fold egwane paren and naive ask
for more information from min a woman
who has the ability to see visions of
the future she predicts naive's death at
the upcoming battle we'll later see men
escaping the city before the dark army
invasion so expect her to make an
appearance in future seasons with the
dark army on its way to the fortress
city of faldarra lord aegomar sends his
troops to the wall at tarwin's gap
meanwhile rand and moraine make it to
the eye in fact the symbol in the center
moraine refers to as the eye when ran
touches it he's transported to a dream
world a vision of the future he can have
if he wants it you can remake the world
in your image in it he's married to his
love eguin and has a daughter a vision
which min also predicted in the real
world maureen holds a knife to rand's
unconscious body as she talks to ishmael
if ran chooses the dark side she'll be
ready to kill him i'll kill him myself
before i let him up while rand is swayed
by this perfect future and it is what he
wants it's not necessarily what egwyn
wants thus he turns from it and refuses
his chamomile's help back at the
fortress parent helps uncover the horn
of aalir only to be blown during the
last battle an item that will call upon
the greatest hearers of the past to
fight at their side but the horn is
stolen by patton feyne who you might
remember as being a traveling peddler in
episode 1. he has secretly been a dark
friend a name given to those who helped
the dark side and if things couldn't get
worse for our heroes the dark army
breaches the wall and king eggomar is
killed leaving his sister lady amalisa
edgwane and naive alongside some other
channelers to prepare a final stand lady
emilisa was in training to become i
sedai but was deemed not to have enough
power it's a fitting end for her then
when she is able to channel all of their
energy into a giant electrical storm
which completely devastates the dark
army in the books however it's rand who
actually does this lady amilisa and
nainiv die in the process but somehow
egwin is able to revive naive which is
quite divergent from the books as far as
how egwin was able to do this healing we
aren't a hundred percent sure just that
the showrunner mentioned we'll be seeing
just how far the powers of these
characters can go in the next season so
i'll leave it up to you whether you
think this is just lazy writing or that
they're setting up something bigger now
i want to talk about patent fame the guy
who ends up taking the horn of elire
likely to be used as bait for catching
rand he ends up killing the oger loyal
with the ruby encrusted dagger matt took
from shiddar logath now the showrunner
has said there are clues as to how he
got the dagger and i spent about an hour
and a half combing over all the footage
and the best i could come up with was
this we know pat and feign has been
following the group throughout the
entire season we also know that the last
time we saw the dagger was when land
picked it up after its hold on mat was
taken out by moraine so it's easy to
assume land still has it in episode 7
perrin catches a glimpse of pattern in
the market escorted by two guards one of
these guards will later see roaming the
residence chambers when egwin goes to
visit naive we also know that patent has
insider information for example he knows
the secret code phrase to be allowed
access into the keep he'd only know this
if he had someone working for him on the
inside who i believe to be this guard a
guard who would have access to the rooms
and be able to retrieve the dagger for
patton that's the best i could come up
with but if you have a better theory i'd
love to hear it in the comments below is
loyal dead well it certainly looks like
it from what we see however the
showrunner has stated that those who
appear dead may not be so it's kind of a
tease and loyal might make it out after
all and heck if edwin has this healing
power who knows what could happen rand
is able to get out of ishmael's vision
not accepting his dream of a perfect
world and something i found rather odd
was as ishmael is being seemingly
defeated he kind of smiles like gives
off this grin almost as if to say this
won't be the last time we see him this
event is also left behind a quindiar
which is old tongue for hearthstone it's
an unbreakable material that was used to
seal the dark one in his prison moraine
believes this as a sign that the battle
we just witnessed wasn't the last battle
but just the beginning ran tells maureen
that he must go on his own and to tell
others that he is dead he sees this as a
better outcome than telling his friends
he'll soon succumb to madness then we
have moraine losing her powers which
looked to be the result of a shamaya now
we're going to get into a little bit of
book spoilers so if you want to click
off do so now marine doesn't lose her
powers in the books and in book 2 she's
only really in about one chapter so to
give her something to do next season the
writers have decided to tell the story
that takes place at tiffin's well and
span that across a whole season tiffin's
well is where moraine and lan attempt to
find answers about the horn of velir and
the dragon reborn rand is likely heading
off to the great city of caimlin this
was skipped in season 1 but is an
important place where several key
characters are introduced including
elaine trekhand who has already been
cast the finale ends with the
introduction of the shan chan empire
this is an invasion that has been
decades in the making they plan on
retaking the continent believing it once
belonged to their ancestors so it's
rightfully theirs they have with them
several powerful channelers who can
manipulate and control giant tsunamis so
this will definitely be a force to be
reckoned with wheel of time season 1 has
come to an end and i want to know your
thoughts below thanks for watching
everyone for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt make sure to like and
subscribe and until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
[Music]
you